honestly he is one of the nicest men
i've ever met in my life um to be there
was a no-brainer kenya moore opens up
about attending needy league's late
husband greg's memorial he was just a
kind gentle
caring supportive man and she was really
lucky to have him
e.t caught up with the real housewives
of atlanta star on wednesday after it
was announced she will be competing on
season 30 of dancing with the stars
i have been a fan of the show for over
30 years and i got an offer to do this
show i was like oh my god i have to do
it the 50 year old reality star revealed
why she flew to atlanta to attend greg's
celebration of life
greg never ever treated me any
differently whether i was feuding with
mimi or not and for that i respected him
so much
nene and kenya were friends in the early
days of their hit bravo reality show but
over the years their friendship soured
and they got into it a lot with real
housewives cameras rolling
hi minnie hey you look fabulous you
don't okay i always do that you want to
look fabulous and really dumb okay
whatever mimi is on 10 and i'm gonna
need her to bring it back down to a two
or three i flew in for
for the memorial um the re-pass
i think
i think it was everything she probably
wanted it to be because people were
happy and i think he would have wanted
people to be happy because his life was
so full and so beautiful and he was such
a great person
so um even though it was hard for me to
be there it seemed like she she got what
she wanted for people to smile and and i
think he would have been happy about
that
greg died on september 1st after
battling colon cancer at the age of 66.
but kenya wasn't the only bravo liberty
to pay their respects and attend greg's
memorial lisa wu phaedra parks marlow
hampton portia williams and eva marcel
were also in attendance and kenya shared
these snaps from the event with her
former co-stars on instagram
you have been my light i couldn't do
this without you i couldn't i wouldn't
even try
so i want to thank you baby
mini first revealed greg had been
diagnosed with stage 3 colon cancer in
june 2018. question i have is
the type of cancer that greg has
the stage that he's at
is it common that is beatable i would
use chemotherapy at this point to try to
reduce that risk of the cancer coming
back greg's fight against cancer played
out on the real housewives of atlanta
during nene's time on the show but as of
may 2019 greg was cancer-free and that
same year nene opened up to e.t about
sharing his health journey on tv
i had a lot of fans to reach out to me
caretakers were emailing me left and
right saying we understand what you are
going through now there were people who
did not understand what a caretaker role
is or they just didn't understand me
saying i was frustrated they were like
why are you frustrated you're not the
one like half there but you know i i was
frustrated because i was a caretaker and
being a caretaker is heart in june nene
revealed his cancer had returned and
last week following his death the 53
year old reality star shared this
emotional tribute to her late husband
dancing to johnny gills it would be you
[Music]
[Music]